good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is Arthur Brooks I'm president of
the American Enterprise Institute and
I'm honored to welcome you to this event
today featuring iMF Managing Director
Christine Lagarde as well as my
colleague Desmond Lachman in a
conversation about what we're
experiencing today in the world economy
the advantages that we see the problems
on the horizon and to get a little bit
of what is in Madame Lagarde crystal
ball about the coming months and years
many of you are as conversant as I am or
more in Madame Lagarde is incredible
background as you all know she's been
managing director of the IMF since 2011
widely considered to be one of the
sharpest minds and financial policy
matters and public policy in general she
started much earlier in her career as
the head of the Chicago Law Firm Baker &
McKenzie and then was Minister of
Finance of France before joining the IMF
Janet Yellen once remarked a remark with
which I concurred that Christine Lagarde
is unique in combining vision with
action before I turn it over to Madame
Lagarde and Desmond Lachman I just want
to say one moment why I admire her so
much and I'm so delighted that she's
with us here today many of you know that
the American Enterprise Institute this
institution which has been around since
1938 is dedicated fundamentally to to
moral principles not policy principles
not financial principles but moral
principles that human dignity is
radically equal between all people with
no exceptions and that human beings have
limitless potential
if only we can find it these are ideas
moral ideals that can be animated and
brought to life on our best days with
good public policy but we need leaders
in the front line that believe in this
fundamental philosophy as well policy
ideas are simply not enough the best
policy leader I know who shares these
views is Christine Lagarde it's
interesting in the world today of
dramatic political and ideological
polarization that it seems that in the
United States and other countries
including France either you're on Team
markets or team welfare that's a false
dichotomy it's
false choice it's a bad choice because
it's not one that we need to make the
truth of the matter is that Democratic
capitalism has pulled 2 billion of our
brothers and sisters out of poverty
since 1970 and one of the greatest
blessings that Democratic capitalism has
and has created is our ability to look
after our brothers and sisters in need
with social safety nets with welfare
programs indeed with systems that
involve redistribution it's not one or
the other it's a creative approach to
how we build the fabric of public policy
remembering the people at the margins of
society no institution has been more
explicitly dedicated to this in the
International Monetary Fund lifting up
nations such that they can serve their
citizens looking out for the people at
the periphery of our society and we need
moral leaders at the helm institutions
like the IMF and we have that and Matt
I'm Christine Lagarde I am so honored to
have her here today sharing our
principles and sharing her wisdom with
us Managing Director Christine Lagarde
and Desmond Lachman well I'd like to
welcome everybody as well and I'd want
to say a special thank you to madam of
God for coming and visiting us again
she's always welcome here and at this
time around she's coming at a very
opportune time just before the g20
meeting in Japan and at a time that the
global economy has got many challenges
so maybe if we start you know if you
could give us you know some indication
of how you see the global economy right
now in April this yeah at the spring
meetings you noted that while the
economy the global economy was having a
synchronized recovery in 2018 it was now
running into a delicate moment you know
and I wonder
how you see things two months later well
thank you so much Desmond and thank you
very much
Arthur for this extremely flattering
introduction but yes the moral
principles that you've referred to I
certainly abide by them and respect them
highly you know it's not without a
little bit of anxiety and some
trepidation that at the last spring
meeting in April we actually coined the
world economic outlook as we presented
it as a fragile and with a precarious
recovery in sight so the test of that
description is really what happens after
we made the forecast and we were in a
way quite pleased and not very happy but
quite pleased to see that this fragility
that we had identified and the
precariousness of the recovery is
actually confirmed and the the 3.3
percent global growth that we forecasted
for 2019 we are maintaining our
certainly this forecast and it's a
downgrade by 0.4 relative to our
forecast of October 2018 so gives you an
indication of this fragility that we
identified because we downgraded and
also because as opposed to the 70%
synchronized pick up that we had seen in
2017 and the first half of 2018 we're
now seeing this sort of synchronized
deceleration of growth which is shared
by about 70% of total total GDP around
the world so that fragility is still the
same it's a little bit differently
distributed than what we had assumed so
most recently the results for the US
economy have have been slightly better
than what we had anticipated slightly
better also the Europe
Union but on the other hand some of the
emerging market economies have been
lower than we had thought
Japan is a bit of an outlier in in
delivering pretty good and solid results
at the moment precarious recovery it
certainly is the case and we are seeing
risks to the downside and some of the
risks that we had identified back a
couple of months ago have actually begun
materializing you know one of the risks
that we had identified is the risks
associated with trade tensions and two
months ago we said be very careful what
you are doing with this major growth
engine that is trade because anything
that breaks on trade such as tariffs
such as non-tariff barriers is going to
actually be a break on growth and
unfortunately we're seeing some
materialization of these risks that we
had identified a few months ago there
are a few other risks that we that are
in the making which are not necessarily
materializing so to speak but breaks it
is certainly a risk on the horizon for
which additional time has been given to
the parties so everybody has now until
October to actually come to terms with
the the the actual exit and the way in
which exit will will take place but it
is still a risk that you know bears as a
downside one so we see the recovery that
we are still forecasting for the end of
2019 and 2020 because we have a forecast
of 3.6 percent for 2020 we see that as
still in the cards but precarious so
that's that's pretty much where we are
thank you I guess though that the
downside risks in some sense have got
more serious you know in that what I'm
thinking about is that we're now getting
a intensification in the us-china trade
dispute and that's now been
to Mexico and there's a threat a little
bit down the road you know that the US
postponed for six months introducing
tariffs on European and Japanese
automobiles 25% tariff you know that's
got to be a rather major risk at the g20
meeting presumably that's going to be a
principal topic of discussion you know
my suspicion is that under Japanese
presidency the g20 meeting of the
finance ministers and central bank
governors will address the issue of
trade I mean I don't see how they could
leave that to the side it's it's a real
topic in the blog that I have released
today which borrows very much from the
g20 surveillance note that has been
prepared for the the finance ministers
and central bank governors what we tried
to do is to actually try to model and
figure out what will be the impact on
growth of what had been announced and is
being implemented and what is now being
threatened in addition to what what took
place and if you combine the two and you
aggregate what is already in place and
what will impact trade only dealing with
China you know let alone Mexico which
which is a more recent development and
we which we have not included in that
particular surveillance note that alone
would shave off the forecast that we
have by 0.5% now you might say 0.5% if
you are you know a country that is
growing at a steady pace and some of the
sub serían countries or even in China is
not a huge amount but if you look at
global growth at three point three
percent this year and most of next year
three point six percent you take off
point five in 2020 which is when we have
calculated the impact of the trade
restrictions you're not talking about
three point one percent absent special
you know fiscal stimulus or monetary
stimulus off of some sorts that would be
put in place if country
are very concerned about the impact off
of the trade restrictions so it's it's a
significant impact and one that is in
the making because you have China you
have what has been announced as you know
potentially implementable soon on Mexico
you have the six months suspension which
might lead to believe a contrary you
that in six months time burying other
developments it will materialize you
have the elimination of the preferential
tariffs on India which only impacts a
very small portion of trade with India
but which is a signal that nothing is
warranted so you know when we try to
analyze from an economic point of view
the impact of those trade restrictions
we actually aggregate several impacts
you have the direct impact of trade
which is not gigantic and then you have
the market impact and then you add the
confidence impact which clearly has a
bearing on investment and and future
decisions of economic characters yeah I
can agree with you totally you know that
the impact could be enormous because
we've just got to think what happened in
November and December when the us-china
trade talks weren't going well we saw
markets slump by like 20 percent so the
impact it seems to me that the trade
issue there really are playing with fire
you know that this could really derail
the global recovery though through the
financial market Channel but hopefully
we don't we don't get there I hope we
don't because I just say that one of the
big differences it stopped me if I speak
to if I talk too much but
what one of the big differences between
now and say you know when we had the
last big financial crisis is that the
space that is available to policy makers
has been significantly reduced you look
at the the monetary policy and the space
that central banks around the world have
not much really not much and and they
have played out many of the tools
available in unconventional monetary
policies you look at the fiscal position
of many countries despite many
iterations reiteration contradictions
and all the rest of it on those those
matters many countries do not have any
space some countries have a little bit
of fiscal space and you count on the
fingers on one of one hand those
countries that have a lot of fiscal
space yeah well I guess that is one of
my concerns is that the largest country
in the world has used its fiscal space
at a time that the recovery was very
strong you know so when the recovery
gets weak it's going to have limited
fiscal space but I guess another reason
for concern about this crazy issue is
that as from playing out in isolation
you know you mentioned brakes it did you
know that we could have a hard brakes
that we just had a bad European
parliamentary election results in the
United Kingdom that looks like it's
pushing towards a difficult situation in
October but then there's also issues
like the Italian government in the
latest election that they seem to be
going down the path of rather
irresponsible fiscal policies so I guess
we're just not looking at this playing
in isolation you know which is I guess
increases the urgency of your trying to
resolve this you know that this is no
time to be opening up another front you
know on the trade side correct and and
you know in in in many ways those
particularly on on trade those are
self-inflicted wounds and it's you know
politics aside on frankly it's
frustrating because we had seen in the
post-crisis period trade decline
gradually over the course of time when
before that it was double the global
growth rate and it was beginning to come
up again and to rise you know but to two
points above global growth rate and if
you look at the WTO numbers if you look
at the the bank numbers our numbers as
well we have indications now that trade
is slowing down yet again and and and
yes that that is a frustration and we
don't need to do that there are issues
they have to be addressed the W system
the WTO system needs to be improved
re-energized in many ways the dispute
resolution system needs to be fixed and
needs to be functional but we don't have
to inflict words to ourselves and it's
you know it's but we're not going to
leave many winners right I guess you
know what one could say is that if the
whole idea of trade restrictions is to
try to reduce external imbalances you
know for instance if you take the United
States if trade restrictions are to try
to reduce the external balance that's
not what's going to do it that what's
going to do it is sound fiscal policies
that the United States needs to save
more and the Europeans Germany perhaps
needs to save less Germany needs to have
an expensive fiscal policy the United
States needs to have a restrictive
fiscal policy what role do you see for
the IMF in trying to get that
conversation going you know that in past
years you had multilateral surveillance
to try to get a better balance between
the various countries reduce the ones
the deficits of ones who had large
deficits
and similarly on the surplus side is
there much scope there is in that we
produce every year something that we
call the external sector report which is
informed by many many many data and and
which has the benefit contrary to the
sort of bilateral comparison that you
are referring to or the current account
assessment on a bilateral basis which
brings all comes all systemic and
critical countries together to arrive at
an overall system where we determine
whether or not the situation of a
country and particularly the situation
of its exchange rate relative to its
position is actually in line or whether
it is not in line with the fundamentals
of the economies what the Japanese
president of the Japanese presidency of
the g20 has done is ask us the the IMF
to produce a special report on this
issue of the imbalances around the world
and and we are producing that report for
the g20 at the Japanese presidency
request what's interesting in the report
is that post crisis we have seen the
imbalances shrink if you if you think of
China back in the immediate pre-crisis
period and you look at China's current
account position at the moment massive
difference it's gone from an you know
eight nine percent surplus to a very
minimal surplus now so emerging market
economies have essentially shifted their
position to being almost balanced and
and where we see now so that has shifted
but imbalances have not disappeared
they've shifted from being within the
emerging market economies predominantly
to being within the advanced economies
and between advanced economies so when
you look at the u.s. situation as you
just indicated
strong deficit if you look at the German
position strong surplus and and and has
been growing although it's beginning now
to decline because the investment of
Germany has now started picking up a bit
so I think the other the sort of I hope
that the collective wisdom of the of the
g20 under Japanese presidency will be to
look at those numbers to look at the
facts
to look at the causes of those
imbalances and there are some legitimate
causes when when a country is aging when
the population is saving then it's it's
obvious that it's going to you know
deliver a surplus but it doesn't explain
and justify some of the surpluses that
we observe at the moment a lot of the
problem is in the area of public
finances I guess you know that countries
that are running big deficits on the
trade side are also running big deficits
on the budget side and it seems that
it's not very logical that if they're
running big budget deficits what that
tends to do is attempts to force the
dollar higher you know which is also
counterproductive so not only are they
saving this but they're having a strong
dollar you know so it just seems at
least to me it seems I guess I've got
more Liberty to say this than you do but
it seems rather misguided to have a
tariff policy to cure this problem you
know that if you're running a big budget
deficit the United States has had the
experience of twin deficits before you
know it looks like we're going down that
path you know that over the past two
years the deficits been increasing
rather then they're narrowing let me ask
quite a different question you know we
mentioned breaks it could be a problem
I mentioned that Italy you know could be
a problem
why don't with you could tell me tell us
going forward what kind of role would
the IMF play in
resolution of a problem you know say
within the eurozone you know you could
argue that in 2010 Europe wasn't
equipped to deal with these kind of
crises but since then they've
established the European Stability
Mechanism the ECB's got the outright
monetary transaction window my question
is would the role of the fund be
different you know would we be seeing
the fund working with a troika or you
know is that something of the past that
the fund might still be involved but it
would be a different kind of involvement
you know if I look back and you know I
started that that period of financial
crisis as a finance minister as as a
player at the Euro group table and then
I shifted to to the IMF in 2011 if
something of a similar nature was to
happen now if there was a euro area
sovereign debt crisis for instance god
forbid because it those were not happy
days and I really hope that it doesn't
happen again but for the purpose of our
discussion here if it was to happen it's
it's different world it's a different
world where as you said the ECB has
explored various mechanisms and tools
that it could use again some of which
have not yet been totally explored but
I'm sure Mario and his successor would
be able to use that second there is the
European Stability Mechanism which is
endowed with over you know 500 billion
euros which was not available at the
time of the you know Irish Greek Cypriot
Spanish crisis and and a few others so
that's also a huge big buffer that is
there and that could be called upon if
a bank was in a very difficult situation
because they've ever they've allowed for
that to operate as a backstop under
certain conditions so that's one not to
say that the sort of incestuous loop
between banks and sovereign has been
completely severe that's not happened
yet and I think that's sort of mission
to be completed there is a resolution
mechanism that has been negotiated
agreed upon and which is enforceable in
all the system in banks in in Europe so
you there are tools there that could be
used I think that both the IMF and the
ECB would if they were asked to
intervene and to help would would
operate in a different capacity I don't
want to speak for the ECB because
they're they're big boys and they can do
that for themselves but for us I think
that we would be working hand in hand
with the ESM if the countries wanted us
to do that we you know we have a
membership of 189 countries the euro
area as such is not a member of the IMF
but each and every 18 members of the IMF
sorry 18 members of the Euro group is a
member of the IMF so we we might again
help if if it was needed but my guess is
that the Europeans who have built this
yes and would want to call on the ESM to
be the sort of first line of defense and
I'm not sure that we would use the
concept of concept of troika anymore
because the troika was the Commissioner
European Commission the European Central
Bank and us I think it would it would
work differently and they're trying to
build fiscal capacity within the ESM as
well in order to build up expertise but
the big difference now is that the
Europeans wouldn't be as dependent on
the IMF financial resources as they were
before because presumably the European
Stability Mechanism has the 500 billion
dollars but more importantly the ECB has
got an unlimited amount of euros
that they could use you know that the MT
is pretty open-ended
well yes and and you might argue that
thanks to the the European Court of
Justice and the various recorded
recourses and the various actions that
were taken against some of the decisions
made by the European Central Bank the
European Central Bank board and and its
president will know within which
parameters it can operate and and with
what prior consent prior consultation
and so on and so forth so there is there
is more more room is it is it unlimited
in the in the way the Fed could be I
think you need to us
I guess Mario Draghi before he goes well
I guess I guess I was just thinking of
his comment is that he would do whatever
it took you know what I guess had better
oh no no we had a big discussion on that
because he said you're right he said
that that was the day when the London
Olympics started we had that same day of
conference and he said because we
debated that he said within my mandate
and it was critically important
particularly if it's Aviv
I think the Bundesbank and the wooden
Bundestag were very concerned that the
within our mandate there was sort of or
true I don't think the market that saw
that they just saw whatever took and you
know I just wonder whether you might not
use that technique in the next crisis
I'll do whatever it takes it seems to
work magic let me ask you in terms of
IMF resources what is the situation with
IMF resources you know in the following
sense you know if we were to have
another crisis you know it seems that
these crises take quite a lot of money
to resolve you know so if you did get
for any reason a crisis it's the IMF
adequately financed or is the more that
you need to do on that front there's
always more than I would that I would
like to do but let me give you two
numbers our capacity to commit at the
moment
is roughly one trillion dollars so with
the reserves and everything else we have
roughly one trillion dollars that is
available and that we can mobilize in
order to help countries around the world
the second number that I want to give
you is 500 billion dollars and the 500
billion dollars is how much we actually
committed during the great financial
crisis so when we had this this massive
financial crisis short of a Great
Depression we committed 500 billion
dollars and I think we were instrumental
together with many others in in trying
to avoid that the Great Recession turned
into a Great Depression so how did we do
that at the time of the great financial
crisis we had and you know in in the
structure of the resources we had quotas
which is a bit like you know hard
capital and there were new arrangements
to borrows that I would represent for
myself as sort of syndicated medium to
long term loans and some of those were
actually converted into quotas over the
course of what we call the 14th review
which is like a capital increase but the
borrowing which is done much more easily
was increased and some of the borrowing
was put into quota what I want to make
sure happens because we are reviewing
our capitals status and our resources
envelope is to maintain our overall
resource anvil op' and short of
increasing the quotas now what I want to
do is increase this syndicated loans the
new arrangements to borrow as it's
called for those who are in the know
here so that the total capacity to
commit remains at a trillion dollars
because you never know the next crisis
can be worse than the last one so we
need to be to be sufficiently strong and
I think we need to give markets the
signal that the fund is going to be
equally strong on the occasion of this
capital
and borrowing reviews so that's that's I
guess one way underway
I guess one area that might give you
some room is that just what we've been
discussing about Europe is that this
time around Europe can take care of a
lot of its own needs you know whereas
presumably lost time around you know the
big IMF programs when places like Greece
and Portugal and Ireland presumably this
time you're going to have the ESM and
the OMT that can help you know so
perhaps you might have some room that
you didn't have in their previous yeah
fair enough I think the the global
financial safety net as we like to call
it has changed no question about that
because the European Stability Mechanism
is one big pocket of financial
availability that is there only for
European countries but you also have in
various corners of the world in Asia for
instance you have the Chennai
arrangement under which countries of
Asia Pacific sort of full description of
the countries in there have also
aggregated resources for the baton for
the rainy days so they have funds that
is available as well under which we have
a close collaboration and which we have
sort of stress tested in order to make
sure that if something happens the
Chennai arrangement which I think has
two hundred and fifty billion dollars
available and us can actually operate
together
in an efficient way and then you have a
few other sort of pockets of financial
resources that are available as well
that could be mobilized eventually I
think what the g20 leaders are all
saying is the IMF is at the center of
the global financial safety net and we
have to play a critical role because
we've been doing that for 75 years this
year it's our anniversary actually and
and we have accumulated you know
experience expertise we know how
conditionalities can fall
don't always do it to perfection but we
we have tried as hard as we could to
improve it and have a recovery rating
which is not bad right well I guess
that's another reason why one would want
the these various trade disputes
resolved because this really doesn't
create the right kind of atmosphere for
International Cooperation or the United
States has had such a role of leadership
of resolving crises working with the IMF
so hopefully that gets resolved pretty
soon this morning you put out a blog in
which one of the factors you mentioned
that is of some concern is the big
increase in corporate ordering you know
that it seems you know the United States
not only in the United States but I
guess the emerging market economies that
their corporations have been borrowing a
lot and that what we're seeing is we're
seeing a deterioration in the credit
quality you know I think that mrs. Ellyn
keeps mentioning you know the United
States leveraged loan market of
something like 1.3 trillion dollars
aside from having a concern there's not
much that we can do at this stage you
know that seems to be a problem that
we've got to live with you know that
that's the result of past policies all
whether there's some kind of policy
prescriptions you had in mind
I think it's a problem that is not only
a problem in the United States the the
corporate the corporate debt is
prevalent pretty much across the board
in all countries and what what is of you
know additional concern to us is the
quality of that of that debt which we
see as having declined here as having
declined in Europe as well in in in many
of the countries comprising comprising
Europe clearly in a period of a
cumulative monetary policy as we have it
and as we will probably continue to have
it and legitimately so in our view until
numbers actually firm up and we see
inflation
had a bit more we are seeing an
accumulation of financial
vulnerabilities that's what we're saying
also in the the g20 surveillance note so
thought of using monetary policy because
we have no inflation because we have
rather sluggish growth then other tools
need to be used and that's where
macro-prudential tools have also been
developed elaborated with I don't think
that we have enough history of the
impact of macro-prudential tools to
actually say well this works this you
should use the kind of collaterals that
are used in those leverage loans should
be transferred or changed but it's I
think it's it's coming along and then
many more central bank governors now who
are you know comparing notes and looking
at prudential tools to see what what is
effectively working and we're beginning
to see good signals but that has to be
you know financial stability has to be a
concern which should not necessarily
interfere with the monetary policy and
which requires in our view an additional
set of tools the prudential tools I
guess I just finished before I turn you
know you couldn't use the remaining time
that we've got for questions from the
audience just questions on the emerging
market economies one the program in
Argentina has had its problems I was
just wondering how you see that right
now you know are they getting things
back on track that would be the one
question and the other is there two
economies that seem to have real
difficulty real crises on the currency
side that could have big impacts on the
economy the one of course is Venezuela
and the other is Turkey and you know
it's just wondering whether their scope
or at what stage can the fund get
involved with those two countries well
first of all we we have to be asked
and that's a big precondition because if
the authorities of a country do not want
to ask the IMF to be involved no matter
how we regret Lamont and and and feel
terribly sorry for the people in some
instances that is certainly the case for
Venezuela
there's not much that we can do all we
can do is prepare as much as we can on
the basis of numbers that we have no
control over an economic situation that
we have not been able to audit for the
last 15 years because we have been
barred from accessing you know the
normal delivering the normal mission
that we that we have with all old
numbers so all we can do is from a
distance and based on sporadic
information and contacts that we have
with a few people who still on the
ground is try to assess what in our view
based on what we've seen is likely to be
just the most difficult protracted and
complicated economic situation that we
have seen and not just economic because
you have a humanitarian crisis you have
a food crisis you have a currency crisis
you have inflation which is in the in
the millions percent and and you and the
debt situation which is extremely
complex as well so you have to bring
this all together it's like having you
know you take the three worst cases of
crisis resolution that we have ever
handled in the history of the IMF you
bring them all together and that is
Venezuela it's like a war situation oh
it's it's yeah it's it's it's really a
turkey mess and we don't have the data
we don't have the tools we don't know we
have not seen it in real in real life
other than them through the prism of the
humanitarian crisis that that is playing
out turkey must be more
that something can be done well I hope
the authorities can actually handle the
situation and can can they have a teeny
tiny bit of fiscal space they have a
private sector that is massively
indebted they have inflation running
high they have a currency situation
which is which is also pretty dear and I
I don't think that President Erdogan
would would actually pick up the phone
to ask me whether the IMF can come and
help but this would be a classic case
for the IMF to do something yes what I
understand but takes two to tango yeah
right
which takes us to our Janina okay that
was a I had thought of that segue you
know in the case of Argentina first of
all I'm reasonably and hopefully
positive about the most recent
developments it's it's it's an economic
situation which was incredibly
complicated as well that I think many
many players ourselves included
underestimated a bit when we when we
started trying to help and put together
with you know with the Argentine
authorities a program to address what
had been critical for the economy which
was the fiscal position which was the
current account position on both those
accounts the situation has significantly
improved and is continuing to show signs
of improvement the the I guess the the
the most surprising component but which
is improving now and the more in the
most recent numbers that we received is
inflation which instead of stabilizing
and gradually declining as as we had
anticipated is showing much more
resilience than we had thought
it is now beginning to decline but it is
it's it's taking longer than we had we
had anticipated you know I'm
hopeful that with a steady continuation
of the program as it is with the
monetary mass as the anchor of the
program as it is now I'm really hoping
that the Argentine program will actually
turn out to be successful for the
Argentine people and for the Argentine
economy there are political you know
developments that will will come into
play over which we have no control of
course and which will be the decision of
the other people but from an economic
point of view very hard legacy inherited
by the previous team difficult situation
to address from all angles
you know fiscal current account
inflation and and the issue of the
exchange rate which is like the
barometer for the people but my hope is
that you know keeping steady and there's
deliver the Macri government is very
committed to the program oh yes they are
yeah yeah yeah well that's what that's
yes with your permission if we let's
just turn it over to questions I think
that what we'll do is just take like
three questions at a time and if I turn
to you if you could just identify
yourself and perhaps please keep it to a
question rather than a statement this
gentleman over here yeah
hi carl galavan historically
constitutionally gold and silver coin
were the money in the u.s. and their
circulation provided great stability for
the working people of course the
velocity at which gold could move
through the economy was a limiting
constraining factor with new blockchain
and wireless technology is it possible
for yet to be gold that to be romana
ties and circulate and exchanged in the
economy digitally and serve as an honest
money
I guess that question was directed at me
I'm originally South African and the on
stage go for gold no no okay
hi thank you marked any mathematical
finance company um one of the issues
with the protectionism by the US is it's
hard for us to sell insurance services
to Africa because they don't have the
risk regulatory framework mark Greene
talked here from US aid and his people
Thomas Ward said that American insurance
companies can't sell into Africa because
they don't have the risk regulation
setups of Prudential wants to sell their
the state of New Jersey would have to do
it
Paul coupie Akkad a IAE I is agreed to
set up a relationship with actual groups
in the US and some of the actuaries in
South Africa were here a couple weeks
ago and they would like to be part of a
project to set up a regulatory systems
for countries in Africa near South
Africa could you come to the question so
the question is would you be willing to
become part of this dialogue that Paul
Kupiec today I is part of of talking to
actual groups in the US and South Africa
you know with the IMF to develop a
capacity to help set up regulatory risk
systems for insurance in developing in
emerging countries thank you Robert
shredder with international investor
Madame Lagarde is it possible that the
multilateral community has relied too
much on trade as the primary engine to
for developing countries to
develop their economies to the exclusion
of other forms of development that
perhaps should receive more attention I
would just take one more Barry would
RTHK and honk on mr. guard you've
attended most of the g20 meetings it's
their ninth year I think how should this
forum be strengthened we know its
strengths but other shortcomings for
example I see there 50 60 people in the
room is that too many the role of gold
and silver and how it can be associated
with distributes and ledger technology
it's something that we have not explored
but certainly we are very very keen to
explore distributed ledger technology
for all sorts of purposes particularly
in the FinTech world and when it comes
to accelerating cross-border payment
when it comes to remittances when it
comes to a lot of the transactions that
are being conducted at significant cost
and with great length of time we believe
that that technology can be of great use
much more I think there is much more
interest in in that technology now
separate and independent from you know
the bitcoins and the a theorem and the
all the rest of them now I think the IMF
card would would actually argue that we
sort of going back to fixed exchange
rate and the sort of guarantee of gold
or silver whatever would actually reduce
the flexibility and the sort of shock
absorbing capacity that flexible
exchange rate have demonstrated over the
course of time and with a financial
crisis as as they went but you know it
although ideas have to be explored and
I think we are we should be open to to
ideas whatever they are American
insurance in South Africa we have a
South African desk at the IMF and
clearly we do not operate at all ever at
the request of any particular groups any
particular segments of the business this
is that this is not our mandate this is
not our mission we act at the request of
countries and we provide either policy
guidance surveillance technical
assistance training and what have you if
South Africa was interested in you know
having technical assistance to elaborate
a better regulatory framework for
insurance distribution development or
whatever we would we would you know
certainly consider whether we can best
do that or whether the World Bank is not
better qualified than we are but it sits
in that relationship between a member
and the institution that that could
eventually be conducted have we relied
too much on the militant lateral system
or as the multilateral system rather
relied too much on on trade to the
explosion of other mechanisms you know
when you look back and when you see how
much has been improved Thanks in
particular but not to the exclusion of
others to trade I don't think that we
should have too many regrets should it
be to the exclusion of other channels of
development absolutely not and and you
know I think that the summit that took
place in Addis Abeba for instance was it
now four years ago when sub-saharan
African countries and particularly
decided to explore how they could
develop how they could reach the
sustainable development goals and
concluded to the fact that it was not
going to be just about trade it was not
going to be just about aid it was not
going to be just about international
institutions but it was also going to be
about they own economic development and
their own domestic revenue
Bizet ssin and having control over their
destiny I think all tools have to be
used and and not to the detriment of
others but I think trade will continue
to play a significant role and it's not
actually randomly that all sub-saharan
African countries have now concluded a
pan-african free trade agreement which
has just recently entered into effect
because it was finally ratified by the
required number of countries and we are
clearly there is a big upside to be had
among sub-saharan African countries in
order to develop the activities when you
look at the volume of trade regionally
between sub-saharan African countries
relative to the volume of trade that
they have off on their raw materials and
commodities with advanced economies
there's a huge upside to be had locally
as there would be a huge upside in
developing and trading services in a
less constricted and less constrained
way g20 are there too many people in the
room you know you're right I have I have
attended I think all g20 leaders summit
ever since the crisis and there were no
g20 leaders summit before the crisis so
I think I've attended them all and I
would concur with many observers who
will say that it's never as efficient as
when there is a crisis because crisis
you know bring about a sense of urgency
a sense of cohesion and need for
cooperation that is you know an
unparallel tool for achieving results
same happened with the construction of
the European Union and what I would have
said that he would have said Europe will
develop one crisis at a time and through
crisis so to many people you know and
I'll give you my personal view it's not
an IMF Orthodox proper view it's my view
I think the problem of the g20 at
leaders levels is that because it goes
from one presidency to the other
each new presidency feels committed and
obliged visibly the previous
presidencies to sort of take over the
legacy and say I don't know the young
you know Japan for instance was it was
very focused and concerned about
population about aging about
demographics well I bet you that I don't
know but I bet you that Saudi Arabia
which is the next g20 presidency will
probably as a courtesy to Japan and out
of politeness and respect for Japan will
say we will continue looking at
demographics and aging and probably look
they will be looking at it from the
other perspective of this youth
population that is coming to markets and
that needs jobs whereas Japan was
looking at it from the other end of the
lifecycle but each new presidency wants
to have its own pet topic so over the
course of ten years you have at least
ten pet topics which have been carried
over from one presidency to the other
and sometimes it's actually healthy when
one member says let's be sensible let's
just wipe out some of those that we have
examined to death and let's just shorten
the list of topics that we are going to
be concerned focused about and where
we're going to be active the lots of
things that you know the g20 has
achieved recently if you look at the
determination of the g20 to fight
against tax evasion and profit base it's
not shifting it's the best base erosion
profit shifting there has been
significant progress you know the
automatic exchange of information in
order to fight those those two
phenomenon I think on corruption I hope
we're going to be able to also make some
some progress going forward
in infrastructure there is a hub that
was set up under Australian presidency
which has been taken over by the two
successive presidency and which is now
delivering set of best practices
best tools in order to develop
infrastructure in a more coherent and
effective way so I think it's it's
delivering value probably not as visible
or nor as much as when we have the
crisis and of the 60 people in the room
you have a good group of them who are
generally sitting in the second or the
third row who are effectively doing the
work so you need them in the room thank
you very much Madame Lagarde you've been
extremely generous with your time and
you've been ready thank and open with us
already appreciate it I would just ask
if people can remain seated while Madame
Lagarde leaves the room but before that
I'd ask you to join me in just thank you
[Applause]